get inspired so here in Seattle outside
the very first starbucks you can see
behind me is the guy singing in my mind
this is the store and I'm really excited
because it's the last week of the
process of writing my book I have to
give the book to my publisher this week
and I'm very close to finishing off
super close and I thought Howard Schultz
Wilson CEO and chairman of starbucks is
a business legend and a mentor of mine
and sometimes I've mentioned in the book
a number of times and I thought what
better place to finish writing the blog
than the very first starbucks everything
sorrowful you go and find something some
place that inspires you some place that
makes you want to think bigger push
stronger and I don't know it just feels
like a nice full circle moment we will
finish writing my book in starbucks and
very her Starbucks and that's it I'm not
answering any questions this week I got
to finish the book sent about fly back
from the Toronto thank you guys so much
for watching I'd love to know in the
comments where you go to get inspired
and create something new and special
leave in the comments for doing
discussion thanks so much for watching
to believe and I'll see you soon Charlie
it's all
this is a quick follow-up I'm also
buying a bunch of stuff to help me
remember today so I've got my Pike Place
copy really good but also buying a pack
of beans hover my desk alarm is being
here and I'm buying Nina tumbler with
the original type place on it so we're
excited